Speaker 1: Today, we're going to be speaking
with Democratic Congressman Raja Krishnamoorthi,
who represents the 8th District of Illinois,
that's the western Chicago suburbs.
He's chairman of the House Oversight Committee
on Economic and Consumer Policy, also a member
of the very important House Intelligence Committee.
Congressman, it's great to have you on today.
Speaker 4: Hey, thank you so much, David.
Same here.
Speaker 1: So, OK.
I mean, to start, we spoke today about for
the first time in his presidency and the real
clear politics average Joe Biden's approval
has dipped just slightly below 40 percent.
It's not great.
It's lower than at this point, even where
Donald Trump was at this point in his presidency,
and that was not good.
I attribute this to sort of a lull in what
we might call major accomplishments to point
to.
What do you think is driving these numbers
and what would you like to see the Biden administration
do?
Speaker 4: Well, I think that COVID inflation
and probably the lack of progress on certain
initiatives in Congress contribute to this,
but obviously, as you know, elections are
about choices.
And I think that we're going to have some
stark choices in the fall.
And but before then, we absolutely have to
do better in Congress.
But also hopefully we can see COVID decline
and inflation come under some control.
Speaker 1: Do you as an individual who's up
for reelection every, every two years, do
you worry when the president's approval is
low that it will affect your reelection?
Speaker 4: Well, I think that the president's
standing definitely affects how different
elected officials and Democrats kind of fare
because of the environment that the president's
standing will influence.
But I think at the end of the day, you know,
voters also try to balance local concerns
and how they perceive their local elected
officials performance based on their own experiences,
for instance, to assess, you know, whether
to support that person.
And so I think the same will be true in this
election.
All that being said, we need to make sure
that the president is successful when he's
successful, everyone successful.
But to do that, we have to make sure that
we deliver for the American people and address
their everyday concerns.
Right now,
Speaker 1: when it comes to something like
the Russia Ukraine situation, I mean, I think
that bad faith actors will criticize the president
and Democrats no matter what is done, either
as being weak or too strong or not being friendly
enough or, you know, whatever the case may
be, bad faith actors will have their criticisms.
But what would you like to see the the the
role of the Biden administration in the United
States on the basis of what happens there
in the next few months?
Speaker 4: Well, actually, I think that the
Biden administration has done a tremendous
job of pulling together our allies onto the
same page with regard to aggression on Ukrainian
new Ukrainian borders.
And I think that.
What we need to see at this point is more
multilateral coordination with regard to what
the costs Russia would face were to invade
Ukraine.
And that means agreeing on a very strong sanctions
regime, agreeing on what we would do to support
Ukraine if it is invaded.
And of course, you know, what do we do to
give Russia an offering with regard to the
current crisis?
If we can do those three things energetically
and in a coordinated fashion, I think that
hopefully we'll get to a better place.
But right now, obviously is a very dangerous
moment.
Speaker 1: What what does your gut tell you
and you know you're on the House Intelligence
Committee, but so so your gut and what intelligence
you've been presented.
There may be some sort of a gray area there,
but what does your gut tell you about the
real objective here of Putin?
Is this to suss out how people will react
without a real plan to invade?
Speaker 4: It's very interesting, and I had
the privilege of attending a classified briefing
with CIA director Bill Burns, who's a tremendous
public servant, by the way.
We had this to our conversation on Monday
and without getting into classified details.
I think that what I can say for sure is that
Putin has a very emotional connection to Ukraine
in the sense that it's almost like a maniacal
obsession with making sure Ukraine does not
further kind of drift into the Western orbit.
Interestingly, all of his actions since 2014
the invasion of Crimea, the the presence of
Russians in the Donbass have further pushed
Ukrainians into the embrace of Western countries.
The second observation I have is that I do
think that Putin, if he is just operating
as a rational actor and setting aside his
maniacal kind of personal obsession with Ukraine,
knows that all things being equal, he doesn't
want to have a situation where he invades
and then has another Afghanistan on his hands,
just as the Soviet Union did 30 years ago.
And I think that because of that, I do think
that there will be a search for diplomatic
options that allow him to save face, even
at the same time that he, you know, kind of
rattles the sabers.
My hope is that his head prevails over his
heart and that we can kind of convince or
persuade him that the costs would just be
prohibitive for him.
And you know, at the end of the day, he might
want to have on his tombstone that he was
the one who joined Ukraine to Russia.
But the alternative could, just as be, could
be just as plausible, which is he's the one
that lost Ukraine.
And so I think that's kind of the balance
right now.
Speaker 1: Is there a discussion among your
colleagues about the possibility that in the
the sort of using the Ukraine Russia situation
as cover that China may see an opportunity
to escalate aggression with Taiwan?
Is that a topic of consideration?
Speaker 4: It is.
I think there's two reasons why potentially
she may not.
The Chinese Premier Xi Jinping may not move
on Taiwan right now, which is a I don't think
that China is prepared militarily to invade
Taiwan.
And I my perception is that they don't think
that they have enough of a military advantage
over the United States in that region.
That's my perception.
That's how I feel.
And then the second is he himself is trying
to consolidate political power this year in
China with the I believe it's the Chinese
People's Congress that's happening in September
or October.
And so he's also focused on making sure that
he can bring all the elites along to basically
rubber stamp his being in office for longer
than perhaps any other premier in many years.
Speaker 1: A couple of other things, and there's
really so much to talk about in terms of inflation.
Similarly to gas prices, we're certainly a
president can do a little bit on some of these
issues, but really, these are big structural,
systemic things that are often global in nature.
What can be done about inflation?
What should be done about inflation?
Speaker 4: Well, I think it's a real issue,
and you don't have to go further than your
grocery store or your gas pump to see that
it's a real issue, and anybody who doesn't
think so is denying reality.
I think there are three things that we as
lawmakers and the Biden administration can
do to tackle this.
First is we have to fight COVID and we have
to make sure that we see a decline in cases
here, but also abroad.
So, David, in that regard, I'm going to put
in a big plug for my legislation and my moves
to really get the world vaccinated at this
point, not just the United States, because
if we see variant after variant come from
abroad, including the Delta variant, which
killed three of my distant relatives in India
and then the AMA crime variant and others
come to our shores, it's going to wreak more
havoc with our economy and lead to more inflation.
So that's the first thing we have to control
COVID here and abroad.
The second thing we have to do is, you know,
those infrastructure investments, which we
approved in the fall have to be directed at
short term logistical bottlenecks that kind
of continue to hamper the supply chain.
So just as an example, we should direct as
much of that money as possible in the short
term to modernizing our ports, to making sure
that our rail facilities are modern and capable
of handling the surge in goods as happened
now having pop up inland ports and so forth.
The third thing that we have to do is we have
to we have to call a spade a spade and note
that some companies are engaging in predatory
pricing practices.
And on my committee, the House Oversight Subcommittee
on Economic and Consumer Policy, which is
a mouthful we launched an investigation into
the meat processing industry, which where
four firms control more than 60 percent of
meat processing and have increased prices
by double digits year after year and are seeing
net profits go through the roof.
And the same thing is happening in other industries.
And so if we do do those three things, I think
it starts to help.
But really, what we need to do is make sure
that we can take the disruptions out of the
supply chain.
That will be the biggest help at this point.
Speaker 1: And to pick a couple of those things,
I mean, on vaccinating the world.
When you look at a world map right now, we're
basically talking about Africa, where there's
the serious lack of vaccines.
I mean, even if you know you look at South
America, there's, you know, in Eastern Europe,
there's still fewer vaccine doses.
But but availability is increasing rapidly,
really everywhere but Africa, as far as I
understand looking at the map, so is that
the area that should be the focus?
Speaker 4: I think that has to be among the
top places that we direct our efforts.
You know, in Africa, it's still, I think under
20 percent of the continent of 1.2 billion
people are vaccinated.
And I bet you dollars to donuts that the next
variant, if it emerges, is going to be from
a place like Africa.
And what we fear is that the lethality of
the next variant could far exceed armed crime
and still have its contagiousness.
And that's what we have to be really worried
about.
And I I'm concerned that we have a real blind
spot here, David, to this issue.
And that's why I and Jeff Merkley and others
are pushing very hard for the White House
to direct more funds, much more funds in this
direction because it's a real, not really
a modest investment compared to the price
that we've paid to repair our economy and
our health care system in other ways.
Speaker 1: So what about domestically at this
point?
I mean, I have a feeling that due to political
reasons sometime between now and the State
of the Union on March 1st, the White House
will likely do some sort of a pseudo mission
accomplished type transition to the endemic
phase statement.
And whether that's medically prudent is a
question that remains to be seen.
But you know, in Illinois, J.B.
Pritzker has said it's going to be time to
start winding down mass requirements.
We're seeing it happen in California, New
York, some places in schools.
Does that make sense to you right now based
on the data?
What are the milestones we should be looking
at otherwise?
Speaker 4: It's an important question.
I think that.
To some degree, it makes sense to wind down
some of these mandates because at the end
of the day, we are seeing a rapid decline
in COVID cases.
And I think there's a lot of public pressure
as well to start to wind down some of those
mandates.
However, we have to be prudent about that
because especially in schools and other places
where a lot of people are yet to be vaccinated
or ineligible to be vaccinated, we just have
to be cautious.
And so I think that striking that balance
is extremely important right now.
But I think that at the end of the day, we
have to stick to the science, David.
We can't just wish this pandemic away.
We're going to have to be very cautious because,
look, we all want to keep the schools open.
We all want to keep businesses open.
We want the economy to stay open and we cannot
ever go into lockdown.
So to prevent that, we have to take these
very basic precautions, such as mask wearing,
masks, distancing and so forth.
Speaker 1: OK, last thing I want to talk about
Nancy Pelosi in December said no to a congressional
stock trading ban in January.
She said she's open to it and now she's actually
supporting it.
Can you talk a little bit about your thoughts
on the issue, but also the specifics of how
such a ban might work in the sense that a
ban on making trades of individual stocks
while in office is a very sort of narrow thing?
And how this applies to significant others
or family members, how this applies to mutual
funds and other things.
I mean, what would you like to see?
What makes sense?
Speaker 4: I think what I like to see is my
bill become law.
It's the bank.
Conflicted Trading Act is the main bill that's
being discussed right now.
It has bicameral, bipartisan support, which
is unusual for anything these days in Congress.
And it's, I think, the subject of negotiations
at this point.
Basically, what it would do is this David,
which is what we know is that the stock act
does not work.
That is the act which basically requires disclosures
of trading of individual stocks and securities,
but doesn't prohibit it.
What we found is that, according to a recent
report, fifty four members of Congress violated
just those disclosure requirements, but hundreds
of others followed those requirements.
But it created a tremendous appearance of
insider trading.
You know, basically, people assume that when
members of Congress pull out their Ameritrade
app and start trading stocks, that they're
doing so based on nonpublic information they
gain from classified briefings and hearings
and insight into legislation.
So the consensus in the grassroots among Democrats
and Republicans is the current system does
not work.
What my bill does is the following it basically
bans or prevents or prohibit members from
trading individual stocks and securities,
allows them to remain invested and to trade
mutual funds and widely diversified funds.
It also, if people wish to trade, they can
do so through a blind trust.
If they wish to keep their stocks, they can,
but they can't trade them.
They have to hold them for the the time that
they're in office.
And at the end of the day, what we're trying
to do, David, is we're trying to restore a
little bit of trust back in Congress here.
And when every story comes out saying that
some member traded funds, you know, bought
Pfizer's stock because they got word that
Pfizer just developed a vaccine or sold Pfizer
stock when they just got word that the pandemic
is actually receding.
That just creates the appearance that they're
trading on insider information, and it erodes
trust further.
S